So, welcome to the last week of
1023.
So, from our usual road map,
we're always in the for the last few
weeks we've been in the top right
quadrant of our road map, specifically
looking at learning based methods for
optimal control. And over the last
couple of weeks we've basically been
introducing the reinforcement learning
setting where we are looking at ways to
estimate value functions,
specifically we introduced Monte Carlo
and temporal difference learning as like
really fundamental
model free learning strategies.
And last week we also looked at one of
the kind of families of methods for
model free reinforcement learning,
namely value based methods.
On the other hand, today we switch
topics and we kind of complete, and if
you wish, and start to discuss the
second main family of methods that
belong to the model free reinforcement
learning family, namely policy
optimization.
And as we will see today, in policy
optimization, differently from what we
did in value based methods, whereby the
policy is implicitly defined through the
value function itself, in policy
optimization we'll see how we'll be
representing the policy explicitly,
namely through a parametric
representation of the policy, and then
tune or adjust the parameters of this
parametric representation of the policy
to directly maximize the reinforcement
learning objective. But long story
short, today we'll be looking at policy
optimization methods.
Specifically, we'll start by introducing
and defining policy gradients.
Which will lead us into kind of the very
first algorithm, which will be the
reinforce algorithm, and we'll discuss
some
kind of we'll do some discussions on the
role of variance of these policy
gradient estimators. Then we'll be
looking at actor-critic methods, which
are extremely popular
instantiation of a policy optimization,
and then conclude with some mention to
kind of recent reinforcement learning
algorithms and and applications.
Okay, so let's start from if you recall
at the beginning of our discussions on
reinforcement learning, we loosely
introduced kind of reinforcement
learning as this
as a problem where we have an agent that
interacts with the environment.
Through this interaction, we generate
some trajectories style which are
nothing else than a kind of sequences of
states and controls that we observe over
time.
And we through this we defined kind of
the formalism for reinforcement learning
as a Markov decision process whereby we
defined a trajectory distribution
P of tau
where P of tau essentially encodes all
the stochasticity that we have in the
environment.
Namely, we could have an initial state
X0 which is sampled from a distribution
over X states.
Concretely, this could be like the dot
reset method in our gym environments for
example.
We have uncertainty that comes from the
policy itself.
So we are defining a policy pi as a
distribution over controls given states.
And so this is in itself is also a
random process.
And then we obviously discuss also the
stochasticity that comes from the
transition function itself which is a
distribution over next state XT + 1
given the current state XT and the
control UT.
Right, so by taking all of these sources
of stochasticity
and factorizing them as was shown here
on the slide, we basically derived the
probability distribution over all
possible trajectories style
as this factorized distribution over
here.
Why was this important? It was important
because this enabled us to define the
reinforcement learning objective,
essentially as a maximization problem
where we want to take the basically pick
the policy pi that maximizes a certain
objective.
And this objective is the sum of
discounted cumulative rewards.
Uh but the sum of discounted cumulative
returns is in expectation where the
expectation is under this trajectory
distribution. Right? So, this is
basically where we started a couple
weeks back.
How does policy optimization go for
solving this problem? As we were briefly
mentioning before, in policy
optimization,
um what we do is
we essentially define our policy to be a
parametric policy pi of theta with some
parameters theta.
And therefore, kind of the reinforcement
learning objective can and the
trajectory distribution itself can
essentially be written with respect to
these parameters uh theta. Right? So,
the initial state distribution and the
traject and the transition distribution
do not depend on theta directly, but our
policy does indeed uh inform the uh
evolution of the trajectory. And
therefore, what we want to pick
essentially is the values of the
parameters theta that maximize the RL
objective.
So, long story short, at at face value,
in policy optimization, we take the
reinforcement learning objective as it
is,
and we uh
basically define it as a optimization
problem with respect to the parameters
of our policy.
Again, going forward to simplify the
notation, we'll assume that this is an
undiscounted environment, but everything
still holds uh when we actually account
for for discounting.
So, um
let us start solving this
um this problem in practice. Right? So,
we saw how
um
well, in value-based methods, if you
remember, we were I you know, ideally
solving this exact same problem, but we
were doing this in an indirect way
because we were doing essentially fixed
point iteration on Q values and value
functions.
And then we saw that that convergence
kind of we derived some theory or at
least mentioned some theory for which um
kind of the algorithms that we proposed
would converge to the optimal value
function and therefore to the optimal
policy. In reinforcement learning, now
we want to solve all these uh this kind
of explicit optimization problem.
>> [snorts]
>> So, we know that you know, before in
this class, we mentioned as a good idea
when we want to solve um optimization
optimization problems that gradient
ascent or gradient descent is a good
approach for solving general class of
numerical optimization problems.
Fundamentally, if we were to approach
this problem through gradient ascent
because we want to maximize this
objective function, we would need to
first of all estimate the gradient of
the objective you're interested in.
And then basically cast learning or
learning the policy as doing gradient
ascent on the objective that we care
about. That is
iteratively take steps in parameter
space following the direction that is
given to us by this this gradient,
right?
So, pictorially, hill climbing our our
our objective.
Kind of our first question here is uh
already kind of we see how our objective
that we wish to optimize
is a non-trivial object, right? Because
we have this expectation under the
trajectory distribution, which is
something which we we don't really know
about because the trajectory
distribution as we said before kind of
has these three sources of
stochasticities, so we can assume that
we know our policy
and we can evaluate the
distribution under our policy, but we
don't really know the transition
dynamics, for example, right? Because
this is the the whole point.
So,
you know, first question is how can we
even evaluate this expectation in the
objective?
And the answer here is by basically
leveraging
the same tools that we'll discussed over
and over of the last couple of weeks,
which is essentially sampling, right?
So, in reinforcement learning, whenever
we don't know some quantity, for
example, the transition functions, we
kind of go around it by sampling in the
environment.
What did we mean by sampling so far?
It's essentially taking rollouts and
interacting with our environment over
time.
So, in other words, we have this
objective that we wish to optimize,
which entails
uh computing the expectation under the
trajectory distribution.
We don't know how to compute this
expectation, and so we can approximate
it by running our policy n times in the
environment and just taking the
empirical mean.
Right? So, in practice, you could
imagine indeed following n possible
rollouts of our policy.
These rollouts will have some rewards.
We will be observing different quality
of the of these rollouts, and then we
simply average out all of the rewards
that we observe over time. And this
would be a valid approximation of this
expectation.
Okay. But so, we mentioned that we want
to approach this through stochastic
gradient ascent or gradient ascent.
Um
the first thing that we need to do is
compute the gradient, right? So, what
we'll do right now is basically derive
uh the policy gradient,
uh and specifically derive um actionable
um
kind of
uh expression of the policy gradient,
and then see how we can use this
expression within a kind of working
algorithms.
Any any questions so far?
Great.
Okay, so for uh compactness, let us
define uh
R of tau uh of the trajectory tau as the
sum of rewards that we observed in a
specific trajectory. So, simply the the
sum of all the rewards observed from
time one until time T within that
trajectory tau.
So, by um
So, we can use this R tau to basically
rewrite the RL objective that we were
introducing before, right? So, J of
theta, uh which we introduced before as
being the expectation under the
trajectory distribution of the sum of
rewards, we can just write it as uh
small R of tau.
And by definition of expectation, we can
write this expectation as the integral
of uh P tau times R tau
in the tau.
So, what we said is what we we want to
take the gradient of this objective
function and use this to hill climb. So,
given this definition or kind of
rewriting of the objective J of theta,
the gradient uh of J of theta with
respect to theta is the integral of the
gradient with respect to theta of uh P
tau times R tau in the tau, right? So,
nothing special here. We just we rewrote
our uh RL objective.
Um and then we're taking the gradient at
face value of that uh objective.
So, here, of course, in
this would not be actionable, right?
Because we would like to evaluate this
gradient and basically take a step in
the direction of the gradient. But, the
problem here is that the how we define
it right now, uh basically the gradient
depends on uh unknown dynamics and the
initial state distribution through this
the probability
uh over trajectories P tau, right? So,
this is still the object that we don't
really know how to compute.
So, here will be essentially what we'll
be doing in this slide in the next is
that we'll be basically massaging this
definition of the policy gradient until
we derive an
analytically retractable and actually
computable expression of that same
gradient.
So, the first thing that we do is we So,
we are realized that this is the, you
know, the object that is creating
problems for us. And so, we leverage
that identity on the right of this
slide. Specifically, the identity
whereby the
probability P tau times the grad log P
can be rewritten as the grad P
essentially, right? So, we know that the
grad of the logarithm of function can be
essentially written as the grad the
gradient of the function divided by the
function itself.
And so, the two terms cancel out. And
so, we get that
kind of useful identity on the right.
So, specifically, now we could we can do
this substitution in our expression of
the policy gradient. And what we get is
that we get the integral of the P tau
times the grad log P times R tau.
Always in the tau, of course.
Now again, we can use the definition of
expectation.
And we can basically rewrite this
integral as the
expectation under the trajectory
distribution
of this part over here,
right?
Now, this is
not
actionable yet because still we have
this expectation and this term here is
not
something we know how to deal with.
But you can probably start to see that
we are somehow on the right track
because we we know that whenever we have
some quantity that is defined as
expectations under the trajectory
distribution, we can just approximate
this expectation through interactions
with the environment and through
something.
So this is one step in the right
direction, but still not completely
actionable because we have this grad log
piece in the equation, which is still
something we don't know.
Okay, so let's keep going.
>> [snorts]
>> So let us recall
as we from you know previous slide the
definition of the trajectory
distribution, right? Which is basically
this factorization of what for us is the
trajectory distribution.
If we take the logarithm of the
trajectory distribution, we products
become sums.
Each individual terms becomes the of
course we take the logarithm.
And basically what we get is the log
piece is equal to these the sum of these
three terms over here, right? So the
logarithm of the probability of the
initial state plus plus the sum over
time of the log pies essentially the
logarithm of the distribution induced by
our policy and the log piece. That is
the transition dynamics.
So we just substitute this in into our
equation of the policy gradient.
And we get this object over here where
Yes, so we are taking the gradient with
respect to theta of this entire term
here, which we derived as the logarithm
of the
probability distribution of trajectories
multiplied by the sum of rewards in that
trajectory.
Now of course notice that since we're
taking the gradient with respect to
theta,
the first the first and the third term
here don't depend on theta directly, so
they don't contribute to our gradient.
Um
And notice that
the only term that remains is actually
something that we know how to compute.
Right? Because the policy is an object
we define.
For example,
the policy for us might be a Gaussian
over
one-dimensional continuous action.
Right? So we could have our U of T.
And so our
policy
pi of U T given X T might be a Gaussian,
where the parameters theta might
represent maybe the mean and the
variance of that Gaussian.
And so basically the log pi's as
are completely specified, and so we can
actually evaluate them.
And so this means that if we take that
expression over there and just rewrite
it compactly over here,
where the only thing that changes that
we re-expanded our terms small R of tau,
we see that we we get an expression of
the policy gradient, which is something
where first of all everything inside
this expectation is known. So this is
just a sum of rewards that we observe
according to some trajectory style.
This is the sum of the log pi's
according to our policy, which again is
something we know how to compute. And so
everything inside this expectation is
known.
Do these steps make sense or any
questions
until now?
Okay.
So we said that everything inside this
expectation is known.
Um how do we evaluate this in practice?
We use the same trick, right? So, we
have this expectation under the
trajectory distribution. We know that we
can approximate this as the empirical
mean
by basically sampling N rollouts uh in
our environment.
We did this before for the objective, so
we can do exactly the same with the
policy gradient, right?
Which basically mean that
uh we can now completely evaluate the
policy gradient that we're interested in
by taking N
um
rollouts or
um trajectories, basically taus in the
environment,
computing this quantity for all of these
trajectories and taking the the mean.
And this will be a valid approximation
of the policy gradient.
Okay. And so, basically,
if this is clear,
through this derivation of
um the policy gradient, this leads us
directly into, if you wish, kind of the
the very first policy optimization
algorithms uh that we will see in the in
this class, which is also known as the
reinforce algorithm.
So, as you can probably imagine, the
the derivations that we derived so far
basically give us an actionable because
now what we can do is something along
the lines of these three steps over
here. So, we will be sampling N
trajectories from the environment by
basically just letting our policy
interact with the environment itself.
Through these trajectories, we can now
always evaluate these gradients
uh or the policy gradient, or at least
approximate it.
And once we have this um estimate of the
policy gradient, we can take a step in
the parameter space according to this to
this gradient to improve the, uh,
basically the quality of our parameters
pi, uh,
theta that represents our policy pi.
>> [snorts]
>> So, taking the bird's-eye view on this
reinforce algorithm according to our
usual skeleton, kind of we have our
usual three components whereby we are
generating samples by interacting with
the environment.
We are estimating a return through Monte
Carlo because we're basically running
our policy in the environment and
explicitly summing up all of the rewards
that we observe at the end of our
episode.
And then we're using those estimates of
the returns to improve the policy,
namely taking a step in parameter space.
Of course, kind of this is, if you wish,
like
one,
uh, step of an inner loop whereby we
would then have to repeat this over
time, right? So, here we're taking one
gradient step, but then you can imagine
that we have,
uh,
outer for loop that is kind of wrapping,
uh, these three steps where we repeat
this process because now we would have
an improved policy with some new
parameters theta, which we'll collect
new experience and we'll use this
experience to re-estimate the gradient
and keep iterating over time.
Okay, but let's stop for a second and
kind of try to build some intuition
into, uh, what policy gradient is
actually doing under the hood and indeed
get some intuition behind the, uh, the
math, which I think it's always useful.
So, we did all of those
kind of algebraic steps to basically
derive
this estimator for the policy gradient.
Right?
Um we explained before how the log pies
essentially represent the
um
log probabilities of uh of the action
according to our policy. And we saw
before how this could be represented
either in the continuous space, exactly
as we were doing here on the slide, but
this is
equally holds if we're looking at the
discrete action space. Uh whereby namely
the policy will be expressing a
categorical distribution over a finite
elements a finite set of actions that we
could pick.
And so this this is basically the term
that we derived.
But let's I think it's useful to compare
it with the expression of the gradient
that we would get when we try to perform
uh max maximum likelihood, or if you
wish kind of behavior cloning for us in
the for the purpose of control.
So, remember the setting of behavior
cloning. In behavior cloning we have
some demonstrations of an expert doing
uh something and executing a task, which
for us namely means uh data sets of
uh tuples of states and action pairs,
uh which basically are examples of this
mapping that we wish to approximate.
Right? So, we want to
uh in maximum likelihood estimation or
behavior cloning, what we wanted to do
is we wanted to maximize the probability
of the actions that we observed from our
expert given
uh given the state.
Right?
And so formally, the gradient in the
maximum likelihood case would
essentially be comprised of this term,
where we're trying to maximize the
probability of the actions in our data
set,
uh because this would essentially mean
be equivalent to uh uh approximating the
behavior of the expert, right?
If you compare this equation of the
gradient
to what we just derived for the policy
gradient, you see that this this is
essentially uh
a weighted version of the gradient that
you would get from maximum likelihood
estimation.
Where the weight is specifically the sum
of rewards in that trajectory.
So, what does this mean is that in
behavior cloning, we kind of taking a
step in the direction of the gradient
essentially means upweighting the
probability of all the actions in my
data set.
In policy gradient, we are upweighting
the probability of the actions according
to their performance in the in those
rollouts, right? So, those actions that
led to higher reward
are more upweighted in my policy
gradient term. And so, we're upweighting
that probability, if that makes sense.
Is this
Is this clear? Does it make sense?
Indeed. And so, the policy gradient is a
weighted version of the maximum
likelihood estimation gradient.
So,
again, kind of to to hammer down this
this idea,
if we take a step in the direction of
the policy gradient, what we're doing is
that we're changing the parameters theta
such that trajectories with higher
reward have higher uh probability,
right? And so, you could imagine if we
have like this fictitious landscape of
rollouts,
where the width of the
uh lines here represents the probability
mass that my policy is allocating to
those trajectories.
Then here we what we want is we want the
good trajectories to be more likely than
the bad trajectories, right? And so
in a way policy gradient really
formalizes this idea of learning by
trial and error because we will
we are running out uh
kind of getting rollouts in our uh of
the policy in the environment. So we're
try trying out different strategies.
And then through uh
basically updates in parameter space, we
are
learning what is more effective and
making it more likely.
And we're learning what is less
effective and making it less likely.
Yeah.
>> In an imitation context, we couldn't use
this approach because we don't have an
explicit formulation of the reward. Is
that kind of why or
>> Uh
I would say
So yes, for example, you might not have
an explicit measure of the reward.
I mean, [snorts] you could construct it
and then maybe reweight your uh
behavior cloning loss, for example. So
this is is something that if you recall,
we did discuss towards the end of the
behavior cloning class where we looked
at uh
So we referred to them as reinforcement
uh via supervised uh methods where we
did have a notion of reward and maybe we
used that to filter the
demonstrations or whatnot. Uh but so at
face value, yes. So this is the the
reason why.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
And so I would say this is
probably the most kind of fundamental
idea uh uh for this lecture. So we
started saying we want to um
approach the reinforcement learning
problem from a slightly different angle,
that is the one of policy optimization.
So, we parameterize our policy, and then
we cast reinforcement learning as an
optimization uh problem
with respect to these parameters of the
policy.
And to do this, we do gradient ascent,
and so everything that we've done so far
is derive the expression of the
gradient.
So, of course, this is not uh
this is not it. There is much more uh to
policy optimization in the sense that
what we discussed so far is great, and
from an intuition intuitive standpoint,
it also makes a lot of sense, at least
uh to me personally. Um
but, I would say that kind of if you
look at this gradient, there are some
clear uh limitations. And I would say
the main one is the fact that this
gradient uh
so, the our estimate of the gradient
uh has extremely high variance. And so,
this is an extremely
uh if you wish, unstable learning signal
uh to follow.
But, so let us
now uh spend a few minutes on uh this
problem of high variance of the policy
gradient. And so, what we'll do now is
we'll first uh
briefly build some intuition to why this
high variance might be happening, and
then we'll look at two strategies for
reducing the variance of the policy
gradient.
So,
um [snorts] so, consider this uh again,
kind of fictitious example here on the
slide. Specifically, here we are uh
kind of visualizing, if you wish, like
on the x-axis, the space of uh
trajectories. So, all possible
trajectories that we may follow
according to our policy.
Um
and this Gaussian here is represent
basically represents uh distribution
over trajectories induced by our policy
pi.
Now, say that we get we basically run
our policy in the environment and we
observe three trajectories and these
three trajectories have some associated
return, right? So, we have these three
trajectories, we sum up all of the
rewards and we obtain these three
specific performances.
Uh now, out of these three, two of them
were positive
in this direction and one of them was
actually negative.
Now,
from everything that we've said so far
on policy gradient, well,
we would expect to policy gradient to do
is that if we then use these
trajectories, estimate the gradient and
take a step in the parameter space, what
we're doing is that we're making this
behavior more likely than this behavior
here, right? Because this is exactly
what we've been discussing so far.
And this is actually what would happen.
But now, let's suppose that we take
those same three trajectories
and simply add
uh
kind of the same positive constant to
the returns
uh to get these three new values, right?
So, the relative gap is always the same,
but what changes is the kind of absolute
numbers of those rewards.
The catch here is that if we now would
do the exact same thing, that is policy
gradient on these trajectories,
uh what we will get is is something
slightly more dispersed. So, because
this is also kind of a positive number
in this case, policy gradient will still
try to
uh
well, it will try to of course give more
likelihood to the better ones, but it
will still try to cover um kind of this
trajectory over here.
And so, of course, this is, if you wish,
like an extreme example, but the main
idea that I'm trying to convey here is
that because we're estimating the true
value of the policy gradient through
samples. Depending on the samples that
we observe, [clears throat]
uh the policy gradient can vary also
quite substantially. Right? And so, this
is exactly what we mean that the
estimator that we came up with of the
policy gradient has a high variance.
Why do we care about this? It's because
in practice, if our
estimator of the gradient that we follow
for learning has high variance, uh this
will essentially lead to worse
performance, slower convergence, and
potentially more unstable um training
curves, essentially.
So, within kind of this framing, uh kind
of I would say that a lot, if not the
majority, of the research in policy
optimization essentially revolves around
finding ways to lower the variance of
these uh estimators.
And so, different algorithms uh
essentially boil down to instantiating
the policy gradient in different ways.
Any Any questions on this?
Yeah.
>> So, rewards can be discrete or they can
be continuous. And the primary
difference between discrete and
continuous like reward gradient
decrease the variance of the policy
gradient? Is that a fair assumption?
>> Uh sorry, could
>> Like if you have like
uh compared like you have like a goal to
play in the setting and then like reach
the goal, you get five points.
>> Yeah.
>> Um versus like uh you get five points
for each step you take towards the
>> Okay.
>> continuous setting.
Um
does supplying a continuous reward
signal decrease the variance
>> Uh
>> of the
>> Yes. I would say that in general, like
um
the more kind of the more dense your
reward is,
uh the better it is for
uh like for propagating the learning
throughout the algorithm, in general.
Yeah.
Uh now, it's not only because of the
variance of the policy gradient, but I
would say in general also for
uh kind of credit assignment, right? So,
if uh it basically it encodes learning
to be more granular throughout your
entire trajectory, if that makes sense.
But yes, your intuition is correct.
Okay. So, let's look at a couple of
strategies to reduce the variance of
policy gradients.
So, the first one
I would say it's more than a simple
trick than an actual strategy. In the
sense that if we look back at what we
were doing to define the policy
gradient, we essentially defined it as,
you know, of course, the empirical mean
because we want to approximate the
expectations. Uh, we have this first
term, which is the log pies, great,
something we can compute, and we were
waiting the log pies by the sum of
rewards throughout the entire
trajectory.
Now, if you look a little bit more
closely into what this is doing, is that
well, it may happen that for time T
prime greater than T
kind of the log pies of this T prime
would still be weighted by the sum of
all the Ts
before T prime.
Which is something counterintuitive,
right? Because
uh, basically the the policy at time T
prime cannot really affect the reward
uh, for the time steps before that
action, right?
And so, this is what I mean by uh,
causality here on the slide. And so, the
first trick essentially entails
leveraging this intuition for the fact
that actions at time T prime cannot
affect the rewards that happened before
it, and simply encode this into how
we're defining the policy gradient.
So, [snorts] rather than
uh, so right now, kind of here I'm just
taking out the this summation to make it
more explicit.
Um, but so, rather than summing from T
equals 1
what we would be doing here is summing
from
uh, T prime equals T,
specifically.
So, this makes sense intuitively, but
why does this lower the variance? So,
first of all, of course, we're not
including a lot of terms
on which the action doesn't really have
any influence on.
And then also, I would say quite
intuitively,
we're summing less terms in our policy
gradient, right? Less terms of the
reward. And remember that the reward is
essentially something that depends on
a number of stochastic elements
throughout the trajectory, right? So,
again, throughout the trajectory, we
will be sampling repeatedly from our
policy, which is indeed something
stochastic. We'll be sampling repeatedly
from the transition function, which is
also something stochastic. And so,
simply put, here we're summing less
terms, and so the there is less variance
associated with this policy gradient
overall.
Does this make sense? This is pretty
pretty simple trick, I would say. But it
does indeed measurably improve things.
The second strategy, which I would say
is
very important for
kind of for the space of policy
optimization methods, is the one of
introducing the concept of baselines.
So, to understand exactly what we mean
by baseline, let's reconsider kind of
the intuition we were discussing before
regarding policy gradient
when we were saying that policy gradient
makes good behavior more likely.
And so,
uh and specifically, what we're
discussing is that policy gradient will
only do kind of
the right thing
if the returns, that is the sum of all
the rewards that we're observing
were centered, right? So, we
specifically consider this counter
example on the right where the relative
difference was the same, but simply
those returns were not centered. And so,
the policy gradient was actually doing
something that we didn't want it to do.
Intuitively, what we would like to have
instead is that we would like to use
some mechanism to center our returns
such that the the policy gradient
essentially becomes something whereby
the probability of behavior that is
better than average gets increased and
worse than average gets decreased.
So, in other words, we want to have a
mechanism to re-center the returns from
our interactions with the with the
environment.
The way we'll do this is through
something that is referred to as a
baseline, here referred to as B, which
is basically a quantity that we are
subtracting to the sum reward, to the
return R of tau.
>> [snorts]
>> So, before we get into
kind of actionable ways of using the
baseline,
I think kind of a
a valuable sanity check here is we're
introducing something in the policy
gradient.
We don't want to change the expectation
of the policy gradient, right? Because
we derived kind of our
equations analytically and we know that
in expectation the policy gradient will,
you know, to the limit of infinite
samples from our
distribution over trajectories will get
the correct object. But now, if we
subtract this baseline B, do we still
get the same the same expectation,
right? Is the estimator still unbiased,
essentially?
And so, the the claim here as a as a
spoiler is that adding this baseline
does not change the value of the
expected gradient.
And so let's [snorts] look at at this
more and more closely.
So to
understand [snorts] this, let's consider
the following expectation. So
um
specifically let's look at
the part of the policy gradient which
only takes [snorts] into account the
baseline. So the grad log P is times the
baseline B.
>> [snorts]
>> Again, from the definition of the
expectation, we can rewrite this as the
integral
of
P tau times the grad log P times the
baseline B.
Right? So here just a definition of
expectation again.
>> [snorts]
>> And now we can use the exact same
identity that we used before in the
derivation of the policy gradient, but
now in the reverse direction, if you
wish.
So we can basically take the
uh P times grad log P's
uh
which is
equal to the grad P's over here, right?
>> [snorts]
>> And so this entails to grad P's times
the baseline B.
Now we can take the
uh B because this is just a constant out
of the integral.
Uh we can do the same with the gradient
operator.
And so what we get is the
um B multiplied by the gradient of the
integral of the probability over tau in
the tau.
Since [snorts] the probability
distribution over trajectories is a
valid probability density, we know that
the integral has to be equal to one.
>> [snorts]
>> And so what we get is we get B times the
gradient of a constant, which is equal
to zero.
>> [snorts]
>> And so this basically makes the estimate
of the gradient
with the additional baseline term still
unbiased in expectation, right? Because
here we basically verified that the
>> [snorts]
>> expected value of the term that we are
subtracting is equal to zero.
And so we're not really changing the
actual expectation of our estimator.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, which I think is something pretty
neat, right? Because basically now we
have this mechanism through which we can
re-center the returns in our policy
gradient
and therefore reduce the variance
uh basically for free, right? Because
we're not really losing anything in
terms of uh bias uh of our estimator.
>> [snorts]
>> Since we what we say is that, you know,
the goal here is to center the returns.
Um a pretty
effective and popular choice of the
baseline is actually to define the
baseline as the average return, right?
So
uh
remember again, here we are interacting
n times with our environment, so we have
n trajectories tau.
Uh for all of these trajectories, we
will have some return. And so we just
define b as the average return
over our trajectories.
We'll see how this idea of average
returns basically motivates many popular
reinforcement learning algorithms, but
for now uh I would say this is uh kind
of the intuition that we are trying to
capture, right? So
remember what we're doing here, we are
interested in using policy gradient-like
algorithms.
We recognized that the policy gradient
is a high-variance object.
And so we want to reduce this variance
through baselines. And here we basically
showed one way of of doing so.
Any any on this?
Okay.
What does it mean in practice to have a
baseline? Again, this is just a kind of
a simple example of training curves, but
to give you an idea is that in practice
what this would mean is that even for
very simple environments,
uh you would get
much faster kind of training
for the same exact same algorithm when
you're just changing the expression of
the policy gradient, right? Um So, here
we're basically looking at it from the
perspective of maybe sample efficiency,
so you converge faster. But in some
cases, this actually makes the
difference between converging or not
converging to a good solution.
So, basically this is what I mean when I
say that
uh
the quality of the estimator of the
policy gradient actually influences
uh training quite substantially.
Okay. So, let's take a step back and
think about what we're doing, right? So,
everything that we've done so far today
is basically defining
a different way of solving the
reinforcement learning objective.
First of all, we
express it as a function of the
parameters theta of our policy.
We evaluate the gradient of that
objective. We saw how to do it. And we
take a a step in parameter space
according to this gradient.
Now, given basically this high-level
structure,
if you recall last week we're discussing
the differences between on- and
off-policy algorithms.
Specifically, we mentioned that an
on-policy algorithm is an algorithm that
uses
experience collected under the policy
that we are using to explore the
the environment to improve.
Uh would you say that this is an
on-policy or off-policy algorithm in
this case?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. So, this is uh
in this specific framework as we've seen
it so far,
uh
policy gradient algorithms are indeed uh
naturally on-policy. Because
the estimate of the gradient depends on
basically the rollouts that we did uh in
the environment according to the current
policy uh pi theta.
The moment we update the policy, we'll
have to collect new experience in order
to re-evaluate the policy gradient for
that policy.
>> [snorts]
>> Of course, there are extensions of
policy optimization. So,
the takeaway here is not policy
optimization algorithms are on-policy,
uh but there are uh for the way we
derived it so far, these are indeed
on-policy algorithms.
>> [clears throat]
>> And indeed, exactly as we as we said, it
is on-policy because we need uh samples
from the current policy to estimate the
gradient.
So, let's look a little bit uh more
closely at a couple of pros and cons of
uh policy uh gradient methods.
First of all,
um
I think it's it's nice to point out how
policy gradient methods naturally handle
uh continuous action spaces.
And this is because we basically all we
have to do is we have to define an
appropriate representation of our
policy.
Phi of u t given x t. For example, this
could be a Gaussian, and we parameterize
the parameters of the Gaussian. So,
same thing if we were to use a discrete
uh
distribution, so a categorical
distribution, we would be essentially
able to leverage the exact same
formalism regardless if the action space
is continuous or discrete.
On the other hand, in value-based
methods, if you recall, kind of the
policy for us was basically implicitly
defined
as an argmax over you
of, for example, a Q function.
Right?
Doing this argmax is obviously easy in
the moment in which this is a the action
space is discrete. So, we have a finite
set of values for our actions you.
The moment you is a continuous object,
then this in itself is an optimization
problem, right? So, which might or might
not be trivial.
>> [snorts]
>> Same caveat here. There are, of course,
methods that allow value-based methods
to be applied for
continuous action spaces, but at face
value, this is a clear distinction,
right?
A second pro is that
by how we derived it,
policy optimization methods directly
optimize the objective we care about,
which is the discounted sum of rewards
over time, right? So, we are
clearly differentiating between policy
optimization methods that take the RL
objective and optimize it
this objective at face value. So, we
literally do gradient ascent on that
objective
from value-based methods such as
Q-learning, which derive a mechanism,
for example, the Bellman optimality
equations to enforce a kind of
fixed-point iteration scheme
that at convergence will also lead to
optimizing that same objective.
But for intermediate solutions, it's not
really clear if there is a partial
ordering, right? So, for policy
optimization methods, since we're doing
hill climbing,
if we stop halfway, we probably have a
good estimate of how much we have been
improving over time.
On the other hand, with Q-learning,
we know that we have guarantees of
convergence, but if we stop halfway, we
don't really know uh
kind of how we are with respect to
previous versions of uh of the policies
we computed.
Yes.
>> For Q-learning, if we stop halfway,
>> Yes, so uh in both cases, remember that
we're looking at like
uh sequential iterative algorithms,
right? So, here, this is basically
gradient ascent, which we take
sequential steps.
Uh in Q-learning, we are basically doing
fixed-point iteration. So, we are
recursively enforcing maybe the Bellman
optimal integration.
In both cases, you might
stop before convergence.
Uh in policy optimization case, I would
argue it's pretty clear to understand
progress because you're maximizing uh an
objective. In Q-learning, it's less
clear how to value uh to compute or
evaluate progress in between
uh before you reach convergence,
right?
But I would say kind of the bottom line
here is that in value-based learning, we
are introducing kind of an intermediate
objective to achieve the same thing,
while in policy optimization, we say we
want to optimize the RL problem, and we
just do that.
The con is that
at face value, at least the kind of
algorithms we just discussed are
on-policy uh compared to, for example,
uh Q-learning, which might be prone to
uh off-policy learning as well. And so,
on-policy in this case can be extremely
sample inefficient.
Whereby
we essentially mean that we might have
to interact with the environment many,
many times before we actually converge.
Okay, any any questions so far before we
we move on to actor-critic methods?
Okay.
And so let's now look at actor-critic
methods which build
uh
I would say quite substantially on all
of the ideas we introduced so far,
namely the policy gradient.
But I I would say at their core
actor-critic methods try to
blend and
kind of leverage the best of both worlds
between
policy gradient methods and value-based
methods. And we'll see we'll see shortly
how.
So specifically consider again the
policy gradient expression we just
derived, right? Which is again kind of
the sum, so the average of the sum of
the log log pies times the sum of the
reward
of our trajectory.
The sum of rewards from time T up until
capital T is also referred to as the
reward to go because essentially encodes
all of the rewards that we will be
seeing in the future of our trajectory.
>> [snorts]
[sighs]
>> And in a way basically all of the
discussions of
the high variance of the policy gradient
that we were doing before essentially
boil down that to the fact that
um
this reward to go is indeed the part
whereby
we have that is basically contributing
to this high variance, right? Because
this reward to go we only have
kind of a limited sample estimate of
what the expected reward to go is.
And the and when we actually sample from
the environment, this might only be
kind of a noisy estimate of the ground
truth expectation we are we are
interested in.
>> [snorts]
>> Why is this
a noisy estimate? It's because again, as
we were saying before, we have we are
basically repeatedly sampling from
various sources of noise. And so even if
we were to take the exact same sequence
of actions over time, we might end in
slightly different rollouts of our in
our environment.
So kind of I would say actor-critic
methods at
kind of fundamentally
say the following. So
rather than estimating these expected
rewards to go through sampling
whereby sampling basically entails just
evaluating rollouts of our policy in the
environment
why don't we try to estimate the actual
expectation by fitting
um
for example, a parametric representation
of that a parametric function to
basically estimate this ground truth
expectation that we that we care about.
And
so at a high level, what actor-critic
methods do is that they define two
parametric functions that we are
interested in in learning. The first one
is the actor, basically our policy. So
our policy pi of theta. So we have some
parameters theta that we wish to
estimate as we were doing so far.
But they also introduce a critic that is
basically a mechanism to estimate more
accurately the expected reward to go
that we would like to have.
How do we do this? This is something
that This is basically everything that
we have been doing so far in the last uh
couple of weeks. Which is basically we
want to estimate the value uh value
functions. Right?
Uh and so we saw before already how we
can use uh for example parametric
approximations to estimate and
approximate uh value functions.
Right? So, very high level
uh what actor critic methods do is that
they recognize that part of this high
variance problem that we see in policy
gradients
basically is uh caused by
approximating the reward to go through
samples.
And so instead of approximating this
reward to go to samples, let's fit uh
parametric approximator of the ground
truth expectation.
Which assuming we're able to do
correctly, then this will reduce the
variance of my uh policy gradients.
So, putting this together, instead of
multiplying my log pies by the sample
return as we were doing over there, so
our reward to go
let's replace the reward to go with an
uh estimator of uh for example uh a
value function with some parameters phi.
>> Does this make sense?
>> Okay.
And so
if this is clear
so this is you know if this is a good
idea, so let's just fit um
uh a parametric function to our uh value
functions.
Can we combine what we're doing uh so
this idea with
the discussion on baselines that we did
before.
Well, the answer is yes.
So, let us try to reduce even further
the value the variance of our policy
gradients
by basically taking
our new
estimate of the policy gradient where we
are using our fitted Q function and let
us add the baseline again.
Exactly as we were saying before, kind
of the intuition that we tried to
leverage in the baseline is that we
wanted to center our returns.
And so, in this case to
center kind of the the our our value
function here, we could pick a
state-dependent baseline B of XT that
depends on states XT
which is the basically the expected Q
function value.
Right? So, here we're basically doing
the same thing. We're sent We want to
center this quantity.
How do we center this? Well, we could
pick B as the expected Q function where
this expectation is taken under the
distribution over controls UT according
to our policy.
Right? So,
even if the exact details here are
slightly unclear, I would kind of I
would say the main idea here that we
want to take over is that
actor-critic methods introduce an
estimate of the value function to better
approximate the reward to go. This is
great. Can we combine this idea with
baselines?
Yes,
we can do that.
We said that with baselines we wanted to
re-center our reward to go term.
We can centering We can center this by
picking the baseline in this way
essentially.
>> Now, let's look at this term a little
bit more closely.
The expected Q function under our policy
is basically nothing else that the value
function itself.
So, this is something that can be
somewhat confusing at first,
uh but let us
try to look a little bit more closely
with an example. So,
consider a discrete environment, again,
for example, our grid world, where
we can take maybe one of a finite number
of of actions.
Right?
So,
we know that the Q function in this case
uh under some policy pi
is basically the
expected reward that we expect to have
in state X
taking action UT
and then following the policy pi uh for
all the state the time steps that come,
right? So, this is the the definition
that we had so far of the Q function.
Whereas, specifically, you see that here
we are basically picking the action UT
because the Q function is defined over
uh this tuple, right? States and
controls.
How can we connect the Q function with
uh the value function for that same
policy?
Is that the
intuitively, the value of a state
is the
average
value that we will get of the
future states, where this average is
taken under the
ex- kind of the probability distribution
that decides which action I'm picking
right now, if that makes sense.
So,
this
value function here is basically
averaging out the future values
according to all the possible controls
that I might pick in that state.
Does this make sense?
Yeah.
>> Like looking over all possible states or
like up actions in the future and then
like you just said averaging them out.
Okay.
>> Yes, I would say the the intuition is
very similar. So, maybe one other way to
see this is temporally, right? So,
basically, the only thing that changes
is the one-step reasoning that we're
doing. Because in the from t + 1
onwards, we're still sampling from our
policy. So, we're averaging out over all
possible things that could happen over
our policy.
In the one-step, so from t to t + 1, the
Q function is basically do has one
information more, which is we are
specifying what control we're taking
right now, right? So, we're basically
committing to one specific action,
right?
On the other hand, the value function is
a function only of the state.
And so, what we're basically saying is
that the value of this state,
if we don't know which action we're
picking in this state, will basically
depend on the average action that we're
picking in this state. And so, the
average action is
sampled according to our policy.
Does that make sense?
Okay. So, this is just basically a small
detour, but I think useful to figure out
what we're saying here.
So, here we're looking at introducing
the baselines.
We mentioned that this was a reasonable
choice of a baseline. [snorts]
We now just saw how the expected Q
function is nothing else than the value
function.
And so we can then rewrite the
expression of the policy gradient as
again the average over N trajectories of
the grad log pies multiplied by our
critic estimator of the reward to go
minus the value function, which in this
case is the policy is the baseline.
And if you look at this term a little
bit more closely, what this term is
saying is that
uh if this is essentially quantifying
how much the action UT
uh is better than the average action in
that same state XT.
And so following this gradient
essentially increases the probability of
actions that are that have returns
better than average.
And decreases the probability of the
actions that have return uh worse than
average.
So this is one way of kind of
recentering um the returns.
This quantity is actually uh kind of so
important in practice that it has its
own name and it is referred to as the
advantage function.
Because it is as if this quantity is
encoding the advantage of taking action
U with respect to uh the average
uh action that I could take.
Questions here?
Yeah.
>> The critic is like agnostic with the
actor. Like you could
like it's like a model of like actions
that you can take in these states. It's
like you can swap out the but I don't
know what
the Q secret is.
>> [clears throat]
>> I know it's similar to something
like a problem. Is that the right
definition?
>> Uh I would say so.
So, functionally, this is a is a just a
separate parametric function. So, there
are two different objects. Of course,
the way we fit the parameters of the
critic, phi in this case, depend on the
policy. Because you can imagine that the
we will be fitting the
our critic depending on the experience
that we have in our environment. And
this experience is dictated by the
policy.
So, I would say this is not independent
because here we're still fitting the
uh value function of that policy, which
for us is the actor.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
>> Can you give an example on how policy
might give you an average action and
what that might look like
for the function?
>> Um so, remember that the policy for us
is just a distribution of actions,
right?
So, in this case, in the continuous
case, could be a Gaussian over a
continuous action UT or in the discrete
case
it might be say we have the four
kind of cardinal directions again and
this is our these are our actions.
The policy might just be a categorical
distribution over
over these actions.
Right?
So, what I meant by average action in
all our discussions of value functions
and so on on the slide was basically
mean we could since this is a valid
these are valid
distributions or actions, we could take
the expectations under these
distributions if that makes sense.
>> Okay, so
this is like they're kind of like just a
classic environment.
>> Uh this is what we call a stochastic
policy.
>> Okay, yeah, okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Going back to question, but um
even if it will be a different critic
based on like the actor, can you like
use like a pre-trained critic so you
don't have to like have it start from
scratch at the beginning of training or
do you always train them kind of
together?
>> Mhm.
Uh
So, I think I I have to answer. This one
answer is the kind of theoretically
grounded answer. I would say no, you
cannot do that. Because this is
uh
So, here we're estimating the value
function. And remember the value
function is an object that refers to a
specific policy.
So, here we want to use the value
function of the policy that we're
learning.
Uh at least for these algorithms that
we're looking at right now. In practice,
as long as
the, you know, this quantity here is
something useful and aligned for
policy updates for grading up uh
updates, then you might get some benefit
in using a pre-trained uh critic. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> What's the like specific mechanism that
you're using to update the the phi
parameters? What is it similar to like
Q-learning or is it something
>> Yeah, great. It's a great question. It's
coming, I think, in one of two slides.
Um
short answer is, if you recall what we
were doing last week with uh fitted
Q-learning or using function
approximators to estimate the value
functions, this is exactly the same
thing.
Yeah, but it's coming in in a couple of
slides.
Okay, and so
uh let's look at uh
So, we mentioned we introduced
actor-critic methods as strategies to
uh try to blend the best of both worlds
between
uh policy optimization and value-based
uh approaches. So, let us even just
visually uh look at an example of a
value-based methods in the top left, so
fitted Q-learning.
And the kind of
kind of V0 version of a policy
optimization algorithm that is
reinforce.
And compare it with
what we're doing here with actor-critic
methods. So in fitted Q-learning, if you
remember, we were well, of course,
running policy in the environment to
collect
trajectories. And then we were
fitting
a parametric function of our value
function, Q-phi,
in order to basically solve our
regression problem, right? So we're
specifying some targets, which could be
either the Monte Carlo targets or the TD
target.
And then we were trying to minimize the
prediction error from our
parametric approximation and the ground
truth target.
In
And this is exactly what we will find in
actor-critic methods. So we still run
the policy in our environment to
generate trajectories.
And here, in actor-critic methods, we
are fitting either a value function or a
Q function or advantage function. It
it'll depend. This is a choice. But we
are ideally doing exactly the same
thing. Right? So in a way this is
exactly the same thing we're doing with
fitted Q-learning here we're doing in
actor-critic methods.
At the same time, while in fitted
Q-learning, we were using the learned Q
function to implicitly define the
policy,
in actor-critic methods, we're doing the
same thing that we're doing in the
reinforce. That is, we are leveraging
our computations here to define policy
gradient expression and use this to take
a step in parameter space.
But so I hope that at least
intuitively you're starting to see how
we're here we're trying to
stitch together different individual
components of of different families of
of algorithms.
Okay.
Now, a question here is um
So, first of all, we, you know, we had
many examples of using value functions
V, using Q functions, or advantage
functions.
What quantity should we estimate and
what are the trade-offs?
I would say in general, there are no
right or wrong answers. I would say
different algorithms might just have
different implementations of the same
underlying idea.
Um
But, for example, one thing that you
might consider is just the complexity of
the estimate value function estimation
problem.
So,
uh for example, the the value function
might be easier because it only depends
on states as the inputs. On the other
hand, if we were to learn a Q function
or an advantage function,
we would have to learn a
a mapping from states and controls
rather than just states.
I would say probably the most um
popular implementation of um
an actor-critic algorithm,
which uses the advantage, also referred
to as A2C or advantage actor-critic, is
something that has this specific choice
of
what we're fitting.
>> [snorts]
>> So, in principle, we want to use the
advantage, which is the Q function minus
the value function V.
Uh of course, what we want to do is we
want to avoid to have to estimate two
objects, right? We don't want to fit
two separate networks, one for the Q
function and one for the value function.
And [snorts] so, the
uh
kind of the the trick that is typically
being used is that we can approximate
the Q function
as the instantaneous reward plus the
value function at the next state.
And so, according to this approximation,
now you can see how the advantage can
uh
>> [snorts]
>> be rewritten as a function only of the
value function V, of the state value
function.
And so, this basically through this kind
of uh reparameterization here, this
enables us to basically fit the
advantage or use the advantage in our
policy updates
while only having to fit the value
function,
if that makes sense.
And so, indeed kind of the advantage
actor-critic algorithm or A2C
uh is indeed something that
runs the policy in the environment, uses
those interactions to fit a value
function,
uh
use that uses that value function to
compute the advantage according to this
uh approximation,
and then uses the advantage to
um
uh in the policy gradient uh ex- um
expression.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay, so now to answer also to your uh
colleague's question,
so here we're talking about estimating
different quantities and different value
functions.
Um
how do we do this, right? And the main
idea is that we simply
uh
leverage exactly what we're doing in
value-based uh methods with function
approximation.
Um specifically, you could do this
through uh Monte Carlo learning.
That is, we collect a data set of state
and return pairs.
And basically build uh do supervised
learning on these uh tuples on these
pairs.
Or we could use equivalently uh TD
learning by similarly collecting a data
set of state and TD target pairs and fit
um and basically solve solve a
regression problem that fits a value
function that approximates and minimizes
the error with respect to this target.
Does this uh clarify?
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. So,
now just as a
brief detour,
I wanted to
briefly go through the AlphaGo paper.
Um
First of all, to show you that you know,
this is now maybe a few This is like 10
2014 or something along those
those times, but uh uh
you know, for it it is one of the
biggest successes of reinforcement
learning, arguably. And I definitely
invite you to check out the paper
because I would say that through
everything that we discussed today, we
actually can understand, I would say,
the entire the entire paper, most
likely.
Um So, starting from uh and I just want
to highlight a couple of I think
interesting points. So, remember kind of
AlphaGo is uh basically this um
uh project where they wanted to learn
through reinforcement learning how to uh
play Go, which is uh
extremely high-dimensional board game,
if you wish.
Um
The idea here was to leverage uh first
of all, define
um
you already start seeing a policy
network and value network. So, here they
use an actor critic method for
for this problem, whereby the policy is
basically something that maps states,
that is board configurations, to
actions,
which is distribution over
a finite amount of next moves in the
board.
And the value the value network is
basically a parametric representation of
the state value function, which
similarly maps from
current configuration of the board or
the state to
scalar number that represents the value
of that board configuration.
Now, if we
skim to how the actual algorithm is
implemented,
so you will see how
So, of course, we train the policy
network by policy gradient reinforcement
learning.
The
It was uh
learned through self-play. So, you could
imagine having the policy kind of
pitched against itself or previous
versions of itself in a simulated
environment.
And so, the games were replayed to
determine the policy gradient update,
which is defined
exactly as we were doing today. Again,
the notation slightly changes, but here
we are basically discussing our
This is the update that you do in
parameter space as the empirical mean
1/M times step size alpha
of the Here we have the grad log pies,
so the probability distribution of
reaction given states, times the
Z here represents the return, so the
return that they observed in the
environment, minus
the value function of the state V.
And here they say that indeed so they
use the reinforce algorithm with a
baseline
V of S T which is basically the value
function as a baseline. And they use
this for for a variance reduction.
Um
again I definitely invite you to check
this kind of the details of this this
paper because I would say that vast
majority of the concepts here we we did
indeed cover today. Yeah.
>> Was there a reward signal to this?
>> Win lose at the end of the episode?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
Uh of course here we kind of glossed
over
kind of one of the main contributions
which is the search element of
of this
of this approach meaning in order to
sample from the policy they weren't just
sampling from a categorical distribution
over action but they were using that
distribution to guide an explicit search
process. Uh specifically Monte Carlo
tree search. Um
but I would say high level intuitions
from the respective of the reinforcement
learning side of things are exactly the
the topics we we covered today.
Yeah.
>> Was what they called the policy they
found theoretically to be
better or was it like a human could not
use?
>> No it is of course the moment you go for
kind of deep reinforcement learning
algorithms
there's no theory that kind of can back
any any of this
in terms of proofs or guarantees of
convergence.
Uh
they were able to beat the world
champion of Go and so
they claim this as a good enough
result for for this policy. Yeah.
>> Why
do you think the human could
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Anytime. Um kind of the full
picture here is that at the time um,
they worm started learning through
behavior cloning.
Uh, and then they but they basically
collected data sets of expert
demonstrations and then they fine-tuned
this through reinforcement learning.
Uh,
jump-starting this work, uh, they
actually showed that the behavior
cloning part was detrimental to final
performance.
Uh, and they just learned everything
through self-play. Yeah.
>> For the final week just as far as
possible.
>> Um,
they mentioned that every
[clears throat] 500 steps, like every
500 iterations, it re-updated itself one
that it was training itself off of with
the parameters that it got for the best.
Is there Do you know if there's a way
that they avoided it like converging on
some policy that it just like went over
those parameters that the other one was
playing with, if that makes sense?
>> Um, I don't know.
>> like a normal self-play policy?
>> They were doing
>> Okay.
>> Um,
I mean, the [snorts] intuition there is
that you want
uh,
increasing level of proficiency also for
your
uh, kind of adversary, if that makes
sense.
Uh,
I don't think I'll have to double-check,
but I think that uh, just by the fact
that you are updating your adversary and
you have kind of this learning loop that
goes around this update, you'll always
be incentivized to find strategies that
are better with respect to your previous
version. And so you're kind of improve
hill climbing in that sense. Uh, but
maybe they did something slightly more
sophisticated. Yeah.
All right, so finish this uh, lecture on
Wednesday. Uh, we'll be also start
discussing uh, model-based reinforcement
learning methods.
Thank you.